[Music]
good food attractive tasty nutritious
and safe
good food the end product of skilled
craftsmen working in one of the world's
biggest industries
chicken salad pork chops spinach and
corn
the simple foods on this tray required
real craftsmanship in their preparation
let's see just when the cook started
this meal
let's turn back the clock to yesterday
morning when the pork loins were
delivered
the other foods were already on hand
pork loins and a turkey
as usual each item was carefully
inspected that's the only way to be sure
of what you're buying
the pork loins were government inspected
and stamped that means a lot to any good
restaurant
[Music]
but not all foods are stopped this
turkey for example
in this case the restaurant must depend
upon a reliable supplier it's the best
anyone can do where government inspected
poultry is not available
government inspected meat certified
shellfish grade a pasteurized milk and
clean vegetables and fruits
to serve safe food a restaurant must buy
safe food and then be sure to store it
properly
[Music]
this completes delivery of the food for
tomorrow's menu it's inspected and
stored and preparation of part of the
meal is already underway
dinner today and lunch tomorrow
making things work out right is a
scheduling job any last minute changes
chicken salad chicken pie pork chops
fish
no everything just as planned
[Music]
here's a good example of plant or
scheduling whatever you want to call it
these are for tomorrow's chicken salad
cooked today and refrigerated overnight
the chicken will be cold when the salad
is made that's important
because cold food inhibits the growth of
bacteria
he's working on a schedule not only
using his hands but using his head
here we are next morning back to today
the day we're going to make and serve
the chicken salad
this is the way to begin the job he's
particular about clean hands everyone
has to be in a kitchen
let's see about the salmon
looks like the chicken is almost boned
now here's the important thing
he's working with cold chicken
cold not only keeps the chicken from
spoiling it makes the meat firmer and
easier to work faster to work
time saving and time is important in an
operation where the possibility of
contamination is so obviously present
you've heard of time and motion studies
it looks like our cook has been
associated with some of that work
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's easy to see how important it is for
cooks to keep their hands clean
everything is planned everything in hand
clean cold food clean equipment and the
know-how
who says this cook isn't a craftsman
[Music]
clean food and equipment and the
know-how
he's still working with cold really cold
chicken
that's important
and he's keeping it cold until served he
knows his business
pork chops
clean cold meat and clean equipment
clean hands
clean equipment and cool food an
unbeatable team
he's taking no chances of spreading
contamination
[Music]
good food
clean equipment and the know-how
someone has to keep everything working
on schedule
[Music]
how about the spinach joe will you get
three packages from the deep freeze
okay
[Music]
proper storage depends on people and
equipment this is a good piece of
equipment
but credit for the way the food is
stored in the chest belongs to kitchen
workers
[Music]
yes food preparation is an orderly job
as long as the people doing the work
know their business
[Music]
good equipment and the know-how
a good cook is a deliberately clean cook
he's conscious of timing and
coordination as well as nutrition and
taste
[Music]
so
[Music]
good equipment and intelligent people
no overcrowding in this storm
and no invitation to rats and insects
either
[Music]
but what's this
a leaking can
spoiled food
put it aside for the moment but get it
out of the kitchen as soon as possible
[Music]
the corn in these cans is clean
let's keep it that way
the top of the cans may have gathered
dust
wipe them off with a clean cloth
and you can be sure this can opener is
clean if it were not it would be an
ideal breeding place for bacteria
[Music]
good clean food
and it's just as clean as it looks
must be getting close to lunchtime
let's check our pork chops
undercooked pork pink pork can cause
trichonosis
according to schedule our pork chop
should be done white pork it's
thoroughly cooked
and now that it's ready to serve the job
is only started
let's keep the food the way it should be
kept until served
keep it hot or keep it cold or don't
keep it long
any good cook has heard this a thousand
times
looks like we're back at our starting
point doesn't it
chicken salad pork chops spinach and
corn remember this tray of food was just
ready to go to our customers early in
the picture
[Music]
while they're eating let's look around
the kitchen
it's a busy place
customers are waiting and more are
coming in every minute that's the
restaurant business it comes in rushes
there's no place for inefficiency in a
busy kitchen
each job is important
every job requires skill
and they're all hard work
[Music]
so
[Music]
but all the skill and hard work that
goes into preparing a good meal is not
wasted
these people recognize and appreciate
good food and the craftsmanship that
goes into preparing it
they're completing a successful meal
from everyone's standpoint
theirs the waitresses the cooks and the
managements
this may be their first meal here but it
won't be their last they'll be back
again maybe tomorrow or maybe next week
and no matter when it is they'll find
safe food
because safe food isn't an accident here
it's a policy
[Music]
no safe food isn't an accident here for
a lot of reasons the cook plans his
meals so that he has little in the way
of leftovers the few that he does have
he stores properly
and like most skilled craftsmen he is
sensitive to his surroundings he sees
that his stove and other equipment is
kept clean
everything is planned and supervised in
this kitchen
a really skilled craftsman doesn't leave
anything to chance
this cook has knowledge and ability
and the way he uses them every day
demonstrates his skill in craftsmanship
his cap is the symbol of his profession
he is proud of it
and he has the right to be
[Music]
you